listen I'm a little upset today I got
into a fight yesterday with an
entrepreneur reader of mine YouTube
watcher of mine let's call him Aaron
because his name doesn't matter so Aaron
writes into me and and he tells me Evan
you know I've been struggling for it for
eight years and we're trying to get my
business off the ground I want to retire
in five years I'm doing manual labor
I've got a software company a tellico
company and I'm not hitting the goals
that I want to hit I thought I'd be
further along and I want to retire in
five years and it's just not happening
for me what can I do and I write back
and say hey Aaron you know sorry to hear
but here's what you need to focus on one
pick a pic one business okay it's hard
enough having a full-time job and trying
to run one business on the side how are
you going to do to businesses on the
side right it's not going to happen you
get you could do one thing really well
and execute or it can do two things in a
really crappy way and not execute you
got to focus successful people focus so
you got to pick one business one
business and do that while you have your
full-time job the second thing is he
writes to Annie says I'm looking for
investors and everything is on hold
until I get investors you got to build
momentum here Aaron you need momentum
right an investor looking at this idea
there's no way he's going to put money
into this you will see that you're doing
something and if he says maybe and you
come back in a month later and he sees
growth this momentum it gets him excited
right think about a Puritan investor
right somebody approaches you with a
business idea and first of all you have
a full-time job
and he has two other ideas that he's
working on you're going to give this guy
money now man of course not like this is
common sense stuff so set Aaron before
you move on focus pick one business idea
and to build momentum don't wait for an
investor the company that's not going to
happen every day take a small step
bootstrap this up so when you go to
investors this momentum there anyway so
Aaron writes back to me and he's like
you don't understand my business you
don't know what you're talking about you
know why didn't you ask me more about
specifics of my company dude it doesn't
matter first of all I'm from the
software business my background is in
software but it doesn't matter it does
not matter what business you're in if
you do not focus and you have no
momentum you're not going to take off
it's simple and he keeps fighting me in
like e-mails back and forth I had to say
the same thing three times and maybe
it's stuck on the last one I don't know
I hope it did for Aaron's sake but he's
fighting me on this and I'm like to if
if you put the effort and energy that
you're taking in being so stubborn and
defensive and take that energy and put
into something positive she'll be
unstoppable then you'll be unstoppable
that's so the message hopefully Aaron
got it and he's going to take action I
don't get anything from helping aaron
apart from I want him to be successful
right he wrote in to me I'm not charging
him I don't get a commission on anything
I just want him to be successful how
many people take the time to answer
questions and try to help you out this
is for you man it's not for me so the
next time you're reaching out to
somebody this is for you guys watching
the next time you're reaching out to
somebody listen right if you're doing
something and it's not working and
you've tried for years and you've lost
all your money doing it and you want it
to work out and somebody gives you a
different perspective hey maybe it's
worth listening to you can ignore it if
you want but your path what you've been
doing for eight years it's not working
so you might want to switch it up a
little bit
people are trying to help you and unless
you change your patterns the patterns
that don't work you're never going to
hit your goals and that's what I want
for you so that's my rant for the week I
got it out I feel better now thank you
for watching if you guys have a story
about people not listening or if you
didn't listen to somebody and you change
your tune and you figured it out you
realize do a right I'd love to hear your
stories leave a comment below let me
know what you think you like this video
thumbs up below click my face subscribe
to the channel thank you so much and
I'll see you soon